die präposition mit wird im deutschen
immer mit den dativ gebildet mit wem
gehe ich einkaufen ich gehe mit meinem
vater einkaufen ich gehe mit meiner
mutter einkaufen ich gehe mit meinem
kind einkaufen
damit ihr euch das gut merken können
dass mit immer mit dem daad ich gebildet
wird werden wir das jetzt mit euch üben
maria war letzte woche in berlin
unterwegs und hat mit menschen auf der
straße gesprochen
das besondere ist alle fragen und alle
antworten beinhalten die präposition mit
und einen dativ das sehen uns jetzt an
mit dem gehen sie ins kino gehe ins kino
mit meinem sohn
ich gehe mit meinem meinen ins kino mit
dem sprechen sie jeden tag
ich spreche jeden tag mit meinen kindern
mit wem kochst du gerne ich koche gerne
mal nach freunden mittags oder abends
meistens bei uns zu hause in der küche
mit dem gehst du ins kino mit meiner
freundin mit dem arbeitest du mit meinem
kollegen mit dem gehen sie tanzen
ich gehe mit meinen freunden gerne
tanzen
mit dem verhandeln sie jeden tag mit mir
selber haben sich jeden tag
es gibt sachen die ich aus kämpfen muss
mit mir selber ich lebe allein und da
ist nicht jemand zum auskämpfen kein
gegenüber muss die sache mit mehr
klarmachen
mit dem fahren sie ins kino
ich fahre mit meiner tochter ins kino
mit wem haben sie in den urlaub mit
meiner frau mit wem arbeiten sich jeden
tag
und jetzt hat gar nicht welchen
elternzeit bin mitgefahren sie in den
urlaub im moment gar nicht mit wem
sprechen sie jeden tag mit meiner frau
mit dem tal sie auto auch mit meiner
frau mit wem freuen sie sich mit der
familie mit dem gehst du ins kino mit
dem trinkst du gerne kaffee am
allerliebsten fink ich kaufe immer noch
wohnen mit wm fährst du gerne in den
urlaub
meistens auch mit freunden für euch gern
urlaub mit dem trinken sie gerne kaffee
mit freunden als trinker gerne kaffee
mit freunden mit wem gehst du tanzen
ich gehe mit meinen freunden tanzen mit
dem förster auto ich fahre mit meiner
mutter auto mit dem gehst du gern ins
kino mit meinen freunden und familie
halt auch manchmal mit wem planen sie
auto
mit meinem kleinen sohn mit dem die iss
ins kino ich gehe mit meinem freund ins
kino mit wem gehst du tanzen
es stehe mit meinem freund torsten mit
vip erst in den urlaub ich fahre mit
freundin in den urlaub mit wem machst du
gerne sport ich mache gerne mit freunden
sport mit wem sprichst du jeden tag
meine arbeitskollegen spreche ich so gut
wie jeden tag mit dem fahren sie gerne
in den urlaub
ich fahre gerne mit meiner tochter im
urlaub mit dem kochen sie gerne
ich koche gerne alleine mit dem gehen
sie gerne raus
ich gehe gerne mit meiner tochter raus
mit dem gehst du ins kino ich gehe mit
meinem freund ins kino
mit wem gehst du essen ich gehe mit
meiner mutter essen mit wem streites du
ich streite mit meinem vater mit dem
sprechen sie jeden tag mit meinem
kleinen sohn mit dem preist du dich am
meisten
ich freue mich mit meinen beschluss
sondern meist mit wem fahren sie auto
ich fahre mit meinem mann auto mit dem
sprechen sie jeden tag
ich spreche jeden tag mit mir selbst mit
dem gehst du gerne einkaufen auch
einkaufen gehe ich gern mit meiner
mutter mit dem gehst du gerne tanzen
ich gehe gern mit meinen freunden club
tanzen und jetzt ist es wichtig dass ihr
das ganze noch selber übt das könnt ihr
tun indem ihr zum beispiel alle fragen
di maria im video gestellt hat selbst
beantwortet und die antworten selber für
euch auf schreibt noch einfacher ist es
wenn ihr einen patch in von easy german
werdet dann könnt ihr interaktive online
übungen machen
zu diesem video und auch zu vielen
anderen videos klickt einfach hier
auftreten dann werdet ihr ein mitglied
von the german hier könnt ihr unseren
kanal abonnieren
und ihr könnt uns auch folgen bei
facebook und bei instagram dann seht ihr
immer wo wir gerade sind und was wir
machen wie zum beispiel in dieser woche
wo wir in japan sind
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und tschüss
bis bald